for nearly seven years grace and everett
fencitfeld
have been waiting for justice for the
deaths of their children
and grace's parents in the mh17 tragedy
it's very difficult day for us you know
to say
it's now the first day of the
prosecution and
yeah it's very difficult for us at a
high security location near amsterdam's
hippo airport relatives of the victims
arrived to hear the next stage in the
murder trial
of the men charged with the 2014 downing
of the malaysia airlines flight
four individuals three russians and a
ukrainian national
have been accused of the attack
none are in court and only one of the
accused oleg pulatov
is being represented in the proceedings
he has denied involvement
a disappointment for the relatives who
remain determined to seek answers over
what happened
participated today are not showing up
you know that is we like to know who
they are etc
but you know we have the status that the
justice
the courts should decide and that's we
trust on that
what follows this week is the dredging
up of bitterly painful memories
of how a boeing 777 jet on route from
amsterdam to kuala lumpur in malaysia
came to be shot down as it flew over
eastern ukraine
now under the control of pro-russia
rebels russia has always denied any
involvement
president putin even blamed ukraine for
not shutting down its own airspace
both an international and dutch
investigation concluded the plane was
hit by a book missile
the prosecution says the missile was
trucked into ukraine from a russian
military base
all 298 people on board died
most of them were dutch citizens over
the coming days the court will hear
evidence of how the victims died
maybe tomorrow will be a heavy day for
the family members
because we're going to talk about
identification of the bodies
but in general terms there are two
three questions was it a book missile
where was it shot from and what was the
responsibility of the suspects
the hearing will continue until early
july and relatives will be able to
address the court in september
in the quest to find answers the details
will nevertheless
be harrowing sonia gallego al jazeera